-Jimmie, you were a NASCAR
driver for 20 years?
-Yeah, basically.
-Yeah, and -- and retired.
-That's a funny word.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
But I mean, what --
what happened,
and what's the difference
between NASCAR and Indy?
-The car performance
of the Indy car is probably
two to three times
of what a NASCAR vehicle is.
So, it's hard to believe that,
just 'cause a NASCAR vehicle
is so fast.
But these little sporty cars,
with the shape of the car,
and the big tires on 'em, and
the speed, they're just a rush.
And I truly thought
that I was going to slow down.
And then I had a chance to drive
one of these Indy cars,
and I thought, "Okay.
Well I'll just try
a limited schedule in '21."
And now I here --
you know, here I am in '22
with a full schedule.
-But I mean,
so what does your wife say?
-Um, yeah, you know,
that's been a -- been a --
[ Laughter ]
-She goes, "Wait, wait.
You were just out.
Well, now you're
in the crazier thing."
-"We're gonna slow down."
And then it's honestly
been busier.
And then the car is a bit more
dangerous and certainly faster.
Yeah.
-How fast have you ever gone?
-The fastest would be in this
car in qualifying last Sunday.
It was over 240 miles an hour
entering turn 1.
-Geez.
-The average speed for the lap,
for the pole -- and my teammate,
Scott Dixon, won the pole --
the average speed for four laps
was 234 miles an hour.
-What do you see
when you're driving 204 --
[ Laughter ]
Like, what -- what do you do?
Like, what --
-It's like "Star Wars"
when they hit the gas
in the Millennium Falcon.
-Yeah.
-That's -- That's it.
-How do you know when to turn
or how to stay on anything?
I mean --
-It's -- It's a rush.
Yeah, there's a lot going on.
-Yeah.
-It's -- It's so gnarly.
Like, that's been --
You know, the kid in me,
the racer in me,
loves that experience.
And it's just been so cool.
-How about
in your personal life, do --
are you the driver
in the family, or...?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Like, could I ask,
if I'm going out with you,
can I ask that your wife
drive us to this?
[ Laughter ]
I don't want to go 220
to the mall, I mean --
-It would be a safer option
for two reasons.
One, you know,
there's less risk,
and, two, you wouldn't have
any vomit in the car.
[ Audience groans ]
I get motion sickness so bad.
-You do?
-I do.
-Wait. What?
-But that --
How is that possible?
-It is.
I don't -- I don't know.
-Do you get sick
while you're racing?
-Not while I'm driving, but
riding in a car, it's horrible.
-Wow.
-Taxi cabs, those guys?
-Well, yeah, okay,
I'll give it to you, yeah.
I'll give it to you,
that's very -- yeah.
-I mean...
-But your whole family's
involved.
I know that your dad
is part of your crew.
-He is this year, yeah.
-He's one of your --
-He's been with me forever,
throughout racing,
got me started.
But he's a crew member
on the race car
for the Indianapolis 500.
-So he's supportive, as well.
-Yeah.
Yeah, he's gonna be spotting
for me -- the guys that --
I have two guys, one on each end
of the speedway,
that tell me where other cars
are around me,
kind of spot
the dangerous parts.
-But how --
if you're going that fast,
how can you tell who's what,
and where anyone is, and --
that fast?
Does your dad talk like an
auctioneer?
[ Laughter ]
Like --
[ Mimicking auctioneer ]
-While looking
through binoculars.
-Does -- yeah, I mean.
Binoculars,
I feel like that's useless.
-But that's how they do it.
-But how could you
even go that fast?
-I tried it once for my younger
brother when he was racing,
and he was just yelling at me
the whole time
because I was looking
at the wrong car
and giving the wrong commands.
[ Laughter ]
It's a -- It's a specialized
form of work.
-Well, I know
that you're not the --
he's not the only family member
helping you out on the track.
Because you're recovering
from a hand injury.
-Yes.
-And your daughter was out there
to give you a pep talk.
And we have a video.
This is very cute.
Take a look at this.
-Have fun.
-Thanks, baby.
[ Laughter ]
[ Audience "Awws" ]
-That's Lydia, my wife Chandra,
and then our oldest, Genevieve,
was off on the side there.
But Lydia gave me
some great advice.
-What were you thinking there
when she was like,
"Yeah, no matter where you
place, you just -- you tried."
-I was very happy to hear it,
but in my mind,
I'm like, "I'm a pro athlete.
I've gotta win.
I've gotta place."
[ Laughter ]
-Like, "Honey, I'll talk to you
after the race," yeah.
-"10 years from now,
we'll talk about this."
-You decided to customize
your helmet
that you're going to wear
for your first Indy 500.
-Yes.
-And you got to design it
with Blake Shelton.
-I did.
-How did you get involved
with that -- with that man.
-That man.
-That animal.
-That beast, Blake Shelton.
-Well, at this point
in my career and life,
I just want to do fun things
with friends.
And to have this opportunity
to design a helmet together,
you know, was something
that I couldn't pass up.
We're supporting
the American Legion.
It's Memorial Day weekend.
Blake's family served,
my grandfather served,
so we've created a helmet --
and really, you'll --
you'll appreciate this a lot.
Blake wanted to sew a mullet
into the back of the helmet.
That was like the one thing that
he really wanted in the design.
-Oh, my gosh, Blake.
[ Laughter ]
Thank goodness you didn't --
not do that.
-Well --
-You thought about it?
-He'll be there Sunday,
so we'll see what happens.
-He wanted to put a mullet
in your helmet?
-He was like,
"Man, that'd be so cool."
[ Laughter ]
"We just put a mullet
in the back,
and you put your helmet on."
-I'm -- what did you --
what did you end up going with?
-We -- Troy Lee Designs
designed the helmet,
and we came up with a really
cool, you know,
patriotic helmet that has some
jets on the top
and our grandfathers --
our family members
that are on the side.
-Yeah, I want to -- I want to
bring -- show you the helmet.
You brought it with you tonight.
-We do.
-But even more special, someone
is going to bring out the helmet
and deliver this to us,
so we can all take a look at it.
Ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome Lydia.
Lydia, are you there?
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
You can come over here.
How did you --
-Thank you, sweetie.
-You are --
Lydia, you are so beautiful.
And that was
a great video message
I saw you did
with your dad there. Yeah.
-[ Chuckles ]
-And I was talking
to you backstage, and I said,
"If you'd like to come out
while your dad's --
you can look from the crowd."
And you go,
"Why can't I be on the show?"
[ Laughter ]
And I go, "Well, of course
we can make that happen."
And I just thought that was
so cute and funny of you.
So, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
Does it feel good?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Here it is.
Oh, my God.
Look at this.
Look at this, right here,
ladies and gentlemen.
-Yes, my grandfather's here.
These are Blake's --
one is Blake's brother,
and the other is Blake's father.
Memorial Day weekend,
honoring the men and women
that have paid
the ultimate sacrifice.
[ Cheers and applause ]
With this helmet.
-Best of luck this weekend.
I'm so happy.
Come back whenever, you know.
-Thank you so much.
-Lydia, it's an honor
to have you here.
Thank you so much, Lydia.
-Thank you.
-Jimmie Johnson, everybody!
Coverage of the Indy 500
starts live at 11:00 a.m.,
this Sunday, right here on NBC.